hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to knock knock oh it's
up in the BA who's a strangely placed
laughed up there in the Attic
well alright Ben so we're back in the
hello it was just another dream and now
I'm back are you sure that was the dream
or perhaps this is it okay so I'm still
hunting around the house looking for
page pieces but I don't know what's real
anymore in the dream world fewer and
fewer days left these are my words these
are my thoughts and this has nothing to
do with sleepwalking whatever it is it
is flesh and blood someone else does
inside my home perhaps it's you but
enough there are lots of books all
containing the same endlessly repetitive
notes I doubt they're useful everything
that makes it my home is also in my head
I've been living here so long that we
are the same thing now that partially
explains you're insane
nope not gonna answer that door not
until I get to where I need to go okay
still hunting around for notes because I
don't want to get don't want to get the
bad and I don't want to get the bad in
what you're seeing isn't really nothing
well okay something cut out there real
quick are you gonna tell me something no
you have nothing to say about that
particular note shut up I don't want any
that's all there is here alright let's
go upstairs and then make the arduous
trek up to the attic I wonder if I
actually really do need to change all
the bubbles in this I mean I need I know
I need to look for the things that I
need to look for better open it yourself
what does that mean what do you mean by
that
I'm not gonna open Oh open the door
myself or wait until the door is opened
hmm interesting
this makes me wonder who exactly is a
knock knock knocking that's not even
close to revealed yet it's very
important that sunrise find you in a
fully restored home your house is always
much larger than it seems
okay all right then so you're saying
that in the dream world I need to get
every light in the house restore I need
everywhere in the house restored before
before I let the clock run out because
otherwise I'll get the bad end that's
not what you're saying
I don't know what you mean okay let's go
get the door squeak would you like to
stay the night squee yes okay all right
we're in the haunted house that's that's
sort of interesting remember I am a new
when it comes to playing this game I
don't know the strategies I'm trying to
learn as fast as I can and yes I am
rather intelligent thank you very much
all right let's go find the little girl
where is this little girl are you
pathari hota the Toto's okay now keep
your eyes peeled there be movement in
these woods scanning scanning scanning
maybe the little girl is the one who's a
knock knock knocking on my chamber door
I don't know though squee nothing yet
just these weird trees with faces on
them branches like fingers reaching up
into the darkness of the night clawing
at my soul yeah I can write poetry too
wasn't really poetry but whatever chop
it's fine I got this
haven't seen anything yet Pepa Tollywood
dippity okay nothing nothing hmm
Oh what does that mean Hey ha ha I
gotcha I gotcha oh he ran away so that
did that was a clue
I was just miss reading the clue that it
was to the left or right instead of
being front to back so all right so I
found her here that I'm gonna every time
there's a sound I'm gonna make a fool
all right maybe not maybe not hmm
oh now you're silent now you're
completely dead silent Oh wonderful good
for me thanks so much for helping me out
game night all right ah ah ah no go the
other way
heard something maybe I can find the
girl multiple times I have no idea no
arrow friggin bird beard okay I scared
the bird away apparently another bird
got scared away damn it
I thought I had her say what again say
one huh who's singing to me I don't know
what's going on here so confused I still
don't understand these woods parts in
fact I don't understand anything in this
game like I said
total newb here don't know what's going
on oh is that Michael Jackson in the
woods there am I gonna catch him with a
bunch of zombies dancing I still haven't
found my house I don't know where my
house went I know it loops left to right
I know that of course it does I know
this
where's my house where's my house
serious serious right now where that a
bleedy bloody is my house BPUT nope nope
nope no house no house it would be nice
can i zoom out no I can't zoom out in
this area dab it dab it where's my house
I want to go home now I think I found
everything I need to in the woods in the
woods in the woods in Meese won the food
you mean ah gosh dang it I I don't know
what else to find I'm trying to go home
could I please could you please aha
there it is alright finally oh that's it
forever
alright back home why is the wind
rustling right here I have no idea but
whatever we're moving forward we're only
two spots away from that big thing
whatever it is let's just go into it
I've always said a lot of time this part
alright let's get into it now our
objective in this one is to restore
every part of the home before sunrise so
that's just what we're gonna do how big
is this place I can't scroll anymore to
see how big the place is well that's
dumb you're dumb you're dumb for being
dumb with your dumb bite are you boom
okay got that restore it restore it with
your mind come on restore it there we go
ah so this was a door I thought this was
like a blocked up thing I guess
technically blocked up but no I have to
get to every say one now what's going on
what's happening
what just happened that was a sound that
I did not recognize
did I hear a squish
did I hear a squish question any more
time but I'm gonna hold off on that I'm
gonna save that until later cuz I don't
think that goes away and I I heard
something in his room
okay maybe not maybe I was a lying maybe
I'm a dirty rotten liar but I thought I
heard something in that room I'm
restoring everything I know I'm not
restoring everything because I'm not
staying in the room long enough to
restore it I'm dumb Mattel me restore it
yep but I thought a minute now thank you
it would take forever to fully restore
everything in here wouldn't it okay well
that's all right then because that's all
the way over there okay okay restore it
who where why we'll find me I'll get
back all right
Jesus a baby's the basement of this
house I have no idea huh no I do not
Oh baby but I want to see you oh yeah
junior squish what squishing something
this wishing well squishes ah crap Oh
what is going to squishy Oh what is this
question
not restored ah
that's far away what is this question I
don't know something goes with these
within the darkness is it this door
where are you baby follow the sound of
my butt who's that
is it what is it who is it is that a
gurney is it a gurney being gir need you
seen nothing you see check whatever
why are you hello what is that sound
squeaky qui what is that something up
there
sounds like Dawn's like it's okay where
are you I don't see anything I I hear
noise oh I see oh wow it is a bad just
bad the bandits are squeaking okay now
that I'm behind you I'm gonna go this
way
Oh a vanished now I owe it back again
open open open up I can't see anything
let's go alright we're going that
light's out but that's okay because f
that uh what do you imagine what are you
cooking up with your Maj a hurry hurry
that's a Gary there's a bad come out of
it thank you god damn it huh
Jesus you take so long to imagine things
now it's a matter with you
come on I don't like you
where is it where is it where is it
where is it where is it I don't see it
no you do not you're dumb your face is
diamond your your butt is dumb as well
every party you dumb that's what you
sound like
oh just Toronto that means a monster
spawn inside it in this house and I hi
hi how are you good to see you get it
funny joke
I don't care I'm trying to restore the
dingdong damned house in this monsters
everywhere I'm not gonna take the cheap
way out huh you're one of them rift
thingies that spawns monsters aren't you
well get out of my house yeah that's
right um I cook up something good for me
today I'm good I'm good
it's not that great but almost ran right
into you
where'd you go alright then look freaky
box headed bastard shut up blacks head
you dumb bastard
Hey oh that was instantaneous scuse me
sorry I didn't mean for that to happen
okay have I gotten pretty much
everywhere in the house now I think so
there's nowhere else there seems to be
to go oh there we go
oh there's a gigantic more to go wait a
minute no have I been there just one
that I've done been there oh the monster
sure are ravenous today but oh you're on
that house was much bigger than I
anticipated but yawn I got some of it
this is how to play the game they are
only visible in the dark first you turn
off the light in your house and open all
the doors as soon as one of the door
slams shut close your eyes and say I'm
glad to see you thanks for coming if you
did everything correctly for a second
you will see a fully set table with the
round loaf of bread in the center at the
table there will be people staring back
at you remember their faces recall their
voices these are the Invisibles that you
brought to live in your house oh good I
can't wait that's phenomenal alright
only one more level until we get to the
big guy but that's gonna have to wait
until next time because I am all out of
time so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
when I get blanket gun
Oh
yeah thigh